when we think of hasha like rengoku Gio
and gyome anime fans tend to think they
are much stronger than our new
generation of demon Slayers like tanjura
zanitsu and so on however in the manga
this is no longer the case and many of
our main characters are now hashra level
or Beyond as you'll see so make sure to
stay tuned for this one smash that like
button until you see fireworks if you
enjoy watching Demon Slayer videos like
this one and want more like them make
this the video you joined the demon
slaying fam by subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
Demon Slayer videos and updates now
first we must start with the most
obvious choice for the next generation
of Hashim Tundra the sun hashira keep in
mind at the end of the series The Demon
threat has been dealt with muzon has
been defeated and the world is free of
dangerous demons so there's no actual
need of more hashira or the demon Sarah
core in general however before that we
did see how strong each of the new
generation of demon Slayers got in what
their accomplishments were and based on
that we can deduce who earned the title
or promotion to Hashim so as mentioned
tanjiro would be the son hashira because
he is a user of the dance of the fire
god style which is also called Sun
breathing the original and strongest
breathing style so there are two known
methods that prove that someone is
worthy of becoming a hashira one
involves killing at least 50 demons
which is the less interesting way but
the other and more interesting criteria
that we'll be using in this video is to
slay a member of The Twelve kizuki thus
if you can beat a lower Moon not just an
upper Moon you are pretty much worthy to
be a hashira strengthwise now all of
these characters that I'm going to
mention including kanjuro have proven
that they are at least this strong or
stronger and you might say that in some
cases they didn't beat the demon Moon
alone so it shouldn't count but as we
saw with sanami who beat a lower Moon
one with Masa chica cuminos help in
order to become the wind hashira you
don't have to solo the demon moon for
this to count and chances are the
stronger the demon keep in mind for
sanami it was lower Moon one the more
likely the demonstrator core is okay
okay with having some help in tanja's
case he first proved he was definitely
worthy enough of being the son hashira
when he outclassed akaza and even the
also present waterhashiragu when Tundra
used the transparent world and selfless
State during that fight he wasn't even
slowed down by an akasa attack that even
gyu's Dead Calm ability had no chance of
stopping Gil looked like he was torn to
shreds while Tanja was able to cut off
upper Moon through his head not only
that the flexes continue he even warned
him he was going to do it beforehand and
akasa still couldn't block or avoid it
in time although akaza if he really
wanted to and gave into muzon's will
could have potentially regenerated his
head at this point and continued the
fight he still admitted that he lost and
suffered total defeat at tanjura's hands
tanjiro had outclassed him in a way Geo
couldn't and so if the day was over
Tundra would have already earned the
sanhashra title especially because there
isn't even occurrence on hasha that he'd
have to be better than to replace now
it's Superfluous to go through all the
other stuff Tundra did like playing the
big biggest role in beating moves on
with sun breathing and learning how to
connect the sun breathing Styles the way
arichi intended even Tundra admits he
wasn't as skilled at doing it as yurichi
but yorichi was the strongest
demonstrated history and all the hajra
pale in comparison to him so that's
nothing that would prevent him from
becoming a hashira so tanjore proved to
be above hashra level during that final
night of demon slaying albeit he did
lose the use of one arm and one eye
after everything was said and done but
if there were still demon threats to
tackle and considering how many half
shells were taken out during the final
fight it's easy to imagine that Tundra
would be promoted to hashira if it was
necessary not only did he take out upper
Moon 3 he also played arguably the
biggest role in taking down the demon
king who the demonstrator core was
formed to take down in the first place
next we have zenitsu who would have no
doubt been promoted to rumble hashira
which is the proper way to call a
thunderhashra in the Demon Slayer World
zenitsu proved he deserved to be a
hashira when he soloed he has soloed an
upper Moon so remember when I was saying
sun and me got promoted because he beat
lower Moon one with a friend who
unfortunately died in the Battle while
sent it to soloed a higher ranking demon
now yes to be fair kaigaku was a villain
after docking gutaro were defeated and
he hadn't had a lot of time to master
his powers as you should have pointed
out but Stills I need to beat a demon
that moves on himself thought was worthy
to hold the upper Moon 6 title that in
and of itself is enough for him to be
promoted to rumble hashira immediately
he and The Talented Prodigy missed
hashida muichiro are the only two to
ever solo upper moons but it doesn't
stop there zaitu also invented a new
thunderstyle form called seventh form
honoi kazuchi nokami AKA flaming Thunder
God this form is the most powerful of
all Thunder forms it takes the form of a
lightning dragon and is so fast that
even a demon enhanced Thunder breath
style user like kaigaku couldn't even
see it let alone Dodge it the upper Moon
couldn't help but think how it was so
fast of course foreign also goes on to
contribute to the final fight against
muzon if there was still a need for a
demonstrator core afterwards there is no
doubt that zenitsu would have been
promoted to the next generation's Rumble
hashira next another character who
earned the title of hashra in my books
is Kano Doma even thinks to himself
before Kano really shows everything
she's got that she might just be a
little more skillful than insect
hashirashinobu that's how impressed he
is by her reaction time inability to
dodge his initial attacks without
inhaling his powder freeze and then
Kanna arguably goes on to play the
biggest role in defeating dolma although
inosuke helps as the shinobu of course
by sacrificing her life to poison Doma
Kano uses one of my favorite breathing
forms flower breathing final form
Vermillion eye during this battle by
raising Dynamic Vision to the utmost it
makes surrounding movements look dull
and slow the pressure on the eyes causes
bleeding that stains them red the
ability allows her to get close enough
to a poison Doma so that all inosuke has
to do is throw his swords into hers for
it to slice through doma's neck and that
spells the end for upper Moon 2 Doma
furthermore like the others Kano keeps
helping after her triumph over an upper
Moon she participates in the muzon fight
and more importantly she uses Vermilion
eye once more to help inject demon king
tangital with medicine so that he turned
back to normal unfortunately after all
this use of Vermilion I her vision in
one eye is gone like it is for tanjuro
her other eye still has some Vision
though as she lets Tanja know in chapter
204 since there's an opening for a new
flower hashira and since kanal was a
tsuko anyway is a hashira's successor
it's not hard to imagine her being
promoted to hashiro she definitely
earned it even if she may want to take
it easy on the Vermillion eye so that
she doesn't lose what Vision she has
left next the obvious choice is inosuke
who would go on to become the Beast
hashira he's arguably in the best shape
after the series ends in terms of
lasting injuries while Tanja lost his
eye and arm Kana almost lost her vision
zenitsu had to be carried by Nesco at
one point because of how much his legs
hurt inosuke alone seems fine so he's a
prime candidate for Beast hashira's
status Beyond being okay after the final
battle inosuke obviously played an
important role during the upper Moon 2
Doma fight with Connell as I mentioned
his Innovative unsourcemanlike idea of
throwing his swords like ninja stars
helped defeat Doma even before the fight
started he proclaimed if I defeat you
I'll be a hashira and he does defeat him
so the rest goes without saying he
earned that title near the beginning of
the fight inosuke even thinks about
being called the beast hashira or the
borehashira asking which one sounds
better it's hilarious stuff now to look
at actual skills that prove he's worthy
of being a hashra Doma Praises how
impressively flexible enosuke is he even
manages to get kano's sword back from
the upper Moon without Doma realizing he
Praises inosuke again saying he's quick
he then surprises Doma who thinks
inosuke is out of range but inosuke uses
Beast breathing
extending bendy slash props to Name by
dislocating all the joints in his arm he
catches Doma by surprise and cuts him
across the eyes inosuke remarks that the
Precision of his new technique still
isn't good and he was aiming for the
neck however we can imagine that he will
be able to perfect this and that will
make the Beast hashra all the deadlier
able to catch demons off guard and take
off their neck in a split second this
flexibility really has to be one of the
most underrated abilities in Demon
Slayer during this fight hidoski also
drops one of my favorite quotes in the
series after finding out dolma killed
his mom inosuke says if hell doesn't
exist all created for you end quote Doma
goes on to notice that inosuke has
sharply sensitive skin and immediately
senses the slightest chill in the air so
he never lets domus powder free slow him
down he Praises him again saying nice
and that he's never met such a swordsman
inosuke survives until he gets the
opportunity to end it with his Beast
breathing sudden throwing strike attack
and of course like the others he
participates in the final battle and
Demon King tanjiro episode he makes it
through all that and arguably recover is
the best which is no small feat thus
with all the hashira batsanami and guiyu
dead or retired you know our boy would
be promoted to Beast hashra or
borahashira I don't know which one do
you guys think sounds better lastly we
gotta mention the demon hashira again
yashina zugawa the little brother of the
windhashira he also arguably proved
himself worthy in the insane fight
against upper Moon while kokushibo the
brother of the strongest demons are in
history yorichitsuki Kuni at first Kenya
thinks he'll be useless in this fight
after all he's fighting alongside
arguably the three strongest
and sanami and they are all stronger
than ever because they have awakened
their Demon Slayer marks however he
remembers what Tundra said the weakest
person has the greatest potential tanjo
antanta say the opponent can only focus
on a certain number of us the rest
depends on how the enemy divides their
attention the enemy is wearier of strong
people so the wall of their caution is
thick if they think someone is weak the
wall is thinner so if a weak person acts
unexpectedly and breaks through that
wall that all at once the direction of
the wind changes and the weight of
Victory appears end quote genya followed
this advice amazingly well and used his
ability to eat demon flesh to eat part
of upper Moon one he undergoes a demon
transformation and we even see a demon
Sarah Mark appear on his forehead we can
assume that he becomes stronger in
relation to how strong the demon whose
flesh he eats is so now that he's eaten
the Flesh of the second strongest demon
you know he'll be strong kukushibu like
eyes surround genya's gun and now this
is like a blood demon art for the demon
hashiraganya the bullets are like living
things and redirect into kokushibu's
flesh even after he deflects them then
the blood demon art causes the bullets
to sprout tree roots that surround and
immobilize upper Moon one if you'll
remember upper Moon 4 specifically the
hatred clone utilized wood and Roots so
it would seem the blood demon art of the
Demons he consumed in the past may be
able to come into play during future
battles meaning genya is just getting
stronger and stronger each time he eats
an other Demon's flesh this attack
succeeds in slowing down kokushibu even
though kokushibu can make blades appear
all over his body that cut the roots new
ones appear The Roots here and block a
demon's ability to use their blood demon
art as kogoshimo says the tree in his
back is sucking up his blood and
extending a trunk yes it's only one of
the factors that helped beat kokoshibo
while muichiro sanami and gyome all
contributed to the eventual Victory but
it's easy to imagine this ability that
slowed down upper Moon one so much could
crush any lower Moon if not even a
weaker upper Moon so we can say at least
temporarily with his demon
transformation genya was definitely
strong enough to be the demon hashira
however unfortunately he died as a
result of the injuries he suffered
during this battle so he couldn't ever
be a hashira of the new generation if
the series continued and there was a new
demon threat yet I feel like the
organization should posthumously give
the late genya honorary hashkida status
for his vital role in stopping upper
Moon one the strongest upper Mount so
there you have it every hashira of the
new generation explained each one of
these characters definitely proved to be
worthy of the title but if you want to
see all 18 of the Demons who earned the
title of demon moon and the history of
Demon Slayer then you don't want to miss
my all 18 demon moves and their powers
explained video link on screen right now
and I'll see you there
right